bien alors on passion à votre roman tom
wolf
mais quand même je demande quand même de
vous certain de ne pas parler le
français
je voudrais pouvoir tant les français
citent les voilà moi la même réflexion
comme ces histoires parce que dans votre
texte
en américain vous citez sans cesse des
mots français alors j'ai relevé
l'expression tout le monde esprit de
corps esthétique de l'abattoir objets
bibelots l'addition monsieur en français
baby des cons et au restaurant ça
évidemment par le français dont tous ces
maux sont en français dans votre texte
américain
oui c'est vrai enfin à presque à chaque
fois je parle de des termes à la mode à
new york
c'est un peu du snobisme est en fait en
matière du goût pour tout ce qui est de
l'intellect de tout ce qui est culture
en fête à new york aux états unis
on est finalement la dernière petite
colonie soumise à l'europe en quelque
sorte
pas seulement pour des questions de
coûts par exemple
bon ce qu'on appelle à des constructions
le déconstructionniste m'enfin ça c'est
là c'est ce cas le plus à la mode à aux
etats-unis beaucoup plus d'ailleurs
qu'elle ne l'est en france dans les
universités mais alors jacques derrida
et tout ça sont très très à la mode aux
etats-unis beaucoup plus qu'ils ne le
sont en france
donc ce que j'essaie de faire dans le
livre c'est de reproduire la voix de la
mode et du snow d'idées du snobisme suis
très content je pense tout le monde ici
est très contents d'apprendre que le
français est toujours quelque chose de
ce noble quand on parle français c'est
quelque chose de ce noble à la mode
c'est formidable c'est juste
enfin enfin je crois qu alors allé à
lyon vous serez très content parce que
c'est effectivement ce qui vous attendra
bien alors l'histoire ce roman c'est une
formidable histoire avec un 1 mort avec
un prévenu avec des policiers des juges
des journalistes afin livre à suspense
etc
mais il n'empêche que le personnage
principal personnage monstrueux c'est
new york
bien entendu alors new york
c'est une ville
vous vivez mais que vous aimez ou que
vous détestez personnellement j'ai à la
fois des sentiments d'affection et
d'horreur pour new york et ça c'est
depuis les premiers jours que je suis
dit ya 26 ans
cette ambiguïté et je crois a fait
partie de tout ce qui est passionnant
dans cette ville il ya constamment un
élément de risque de danger dans cette
quête dans cette ville et j'ai cette
ambiguïté oui
d'habitude dans les romans ou dans la
vie on raconte des histoires de blancs
riches qui font condamné injustement des
noirs pauvres et vous vous raconter une
histoire je dirais presque inverse c'est
à dire c'est un riche blanc qui se fait
condamner d'une manière assez injuste
par des noirs de pauvres et par défaut
d'aider blanc aussi un pauvre c'est un
peu le monde renversé ce que ça n'est
pas une histoire très provocante que
vous avez raconté
mais c'est justement toute l'ironie de
la vie à new york c'est ça que j'essaye
de faire transparaître dans mon ouvrage
vous avez là un millionnaire de wall
street qui habite par cabinet ou qui est
née avec tous les avantages et
privilèges du monde il a toujours vu la
richesse avec lui et puis tout d'un coup
ils découvrent et ceci est tout à fait
vrai dans la vie de new york
il découvre que lorsqu'on rentre dans
les mécanismes politiques qui régissent
la vie new york et bien tous ces
privilèges de vienne se retourne contre
vous et devient des désavantages et ceci
a provoqué un changement et ceci est dû
aussi un changement dans la vie
américaine qui est le suivant ce n'est
plus le blanc qui vient d'origine
européenne qui dirige le monde
en effet cette nouvelle vague
d'émigration aux états unis vient
d'abord d'amérique latine du mexique et
d'asie or tout ce monde immigrés
peu à peu s'intègre dans la vie
politique
new yorkaise américaine en général et
vous avez donc des juges des procureurs
qui cherche désespérément leurs accusé
blanc ils veulent le coupable devant
pour pouvoir montrer au peuple noir la
justice keller évidemment ce n'est même
plus de la justice qu'il s'agit oui mais
on a l'impression que new york est le
théâtre de batailles ethnique et il y à
il ya les noirs il ya les portoricains
il ya les juifs il ya les irlandais etc
et toutes ces ethnies ne peuvent pas se
supporter les unes les autres
très juste enfin on m'a beaucoup
critiqué d'ailleurs pour avoir présenté
brossé un tableau aussi franc que je les
fais en fait ce n'est pas tellement des
conflits raciaux
il ya également des conflits internes
dans les races dans les milieux
ethniques alors et je crois que s'il
représente un peu la situation
américaine des new york
en fait j'essaie de faire la ville de
new york toujours présente à l'arrière
plan j'essaye à un petit peu en forme à
comparer aux zola de paris au dickens de
londres en mettant toujours à
l'arrière-plan la ville dans laquelle se
passe l'action et à new york la ville
est toujours présente on réfléchit
toujours lorsqu'on est à nouveau en
termes d'identité ethnique quel que soit
d'ailleurs les goûts politique même si
un homme dit qu'il est libéré de tous et
snobisme mais bien quand même ils
s'identifient à une classe sera sien
[Musique]